Finally, guys, it is Tuesday,
it is time for "WeTweet."
Here we go!
-♪ WeTweet ♪
♪♪
♪ WeTweet ♪
-Alright. Welcome to "WeTweet."
This is where we, as a group,
decide something
that we should post on Twitter.
I'm going to show you
five different tweets,
and we're all going to vote on
whether we like each one or not.
You all have voting clickers
at your seats.
Yep. I see yours.
Hi. Yep, very good.
Alright. Good. You can vote
for all of them if you like.
If it makes you feel good,
vote for all of them.
You can vote for none of them.
If you don't feel like playing,
it's fine.
Just enjoy yourselves.
We're gonna see
the results live.
Higgins, Roots,
you guys have clickers, too?
-Got it.
-Yep, yep.
-Alright, good.
Whatever gets the most likes,
we're going to tweet it out
live on the show
during commercial break
so you can all like it
and all "WeTweet" it.
[ Audience ahhs ]
It's a shared experience.
Alright,
you guys ready for this?
Alright. The first tweet is...
[ Laughter ]
I don't think
people do that anymore.
-Right.
-Oh, I do.
-Like, dunk --
-Actually dunk the Dunkin'
in the donut?
-It used to be a thing
people do.
-Earlier, donuts used
to be way more dense,
so you had to dunk it.
-Yeah, they were drier.
-Yeah.
-And now there's enough moisture
that you don't need
to dunk the donuts.
-They're moist. Moist.
-Don't say m--
-Moist?
-No, just say "moisture."
-"Moisture."
-Alright.
Here we go. The votes are in.
Let's see the results
right here.
Alright. Okay.
That's not bad, yeah. Not --
Okay. Didn't like it.
Didn't hate it.
Alright. I understand.
Very honest audience.
This next one says...
Yeah, I've been there.
-That's nice.
-I've been there.
Yeah, I go -- Alright.
Uncle Larry.
-You got over there.
-Yeah, you should
sit away from us.
Alright. Very good.
Let's see the results
on this one.
Alright. Not bad.
It's much better.
-Ohh.
-That's what I'm talking about.
I appreciate that. Thank you.
It really is an honest audience.
Okay. Good. 137?
-1-3-7. That's not bad.
-That's pretty good.
That's a good number, yeah.
Alright.
This next one here says...
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Yeah.
-"Hey, man!"
♪♪
Right? He's like...
-Yeah. Alright.
-♪ Walk like... ♪
-Let's see the results here.
Ohh!
That's gonna be the winner.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You're gonna tell me
there was not one goofy dude
walking around Athens?
-Not one.
-Having a good time in Athens?
Come on.
Alright.
Next -- Oh, this one
I'm not sure if you're
gonna like this or not.
Mm.
Hm. I mean,
there's no specific order.
So this one could be,
you know, tough.
Alright.
Well, I set it up pretty bad.
-You don't care for it.
-Maybe it might be great.
-Might be -- Should be --
Yeah, it's going to be great.
No?
-Yeah. No.
-It says...
-I edited it and handed it in.
I edited it and handed it in.
-It's just hard. Yeah.
It actually is hard to say.
I don't even think
I'm gonna do it.
-Try it.
-No, I'm not gonna vote for it.
-It's not that fun.
-You're going against
your own vote?
-I'm gonna go against my own --
I voted down on this one.
-You vote down?
-Yeah.
This one might be the lowest
in "WeTweet" history.
-Really?
-I edited it --
I edited it and handed it in.
[ Speaking gibberish ]
Alright.
Let's see the results here.
-Yeah.
-[ Sad tuba plays ]
-[ Laughs ] Wow.
-Damn.
-[ Laughs ] Wow!
I knew it was bad.
Yeah, I knew it.
This last one's got potential.
-Really?
-Yeah. What do we gotta beat?
What number?
-1-6-1.
-161?
-Yeah.
-I think this one --
-You think this one's a winner.
-I think this one's
going all the way.
Last one says...
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
"What's that?
What's that? Yeah. What?
Yeah. Oh, yeah, yeah. Thank you.
I know. I like to -- Yeah.
I enjoy...
What's that?
Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes,
yes, yes, yes. Exactly.
Huh? No, I didn't see --
I haven't seen
'White Lotus' yet.
No, I'm going to watch it
this weekend."
Let's see the results
right here.
-Ohh!
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
The winner right there!
[ Bell dinging ]
There you go!
Take your earbuds out.
I'm gonna post this
during the commercial break.
If you see it on your feed,
give it a like,
give it a WeTweet, and enjoy.